hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown president biden
calls on congress to ban assault weapons
or raise the age to buy a gun from 18 to
21. gop senator rand paul of kentucky
weighs in on the growing debate over gun
laws in the wake of several mass
shootings and shares his plan to help
boost the economy
a verdict in johnny depp's high-profile
defamation lawsuit against ex-wife amber
hurd a virginia jury largely siding with
depp awarding him over 10 million
dollars in damages criminal defense
attorney jonas billboar breaks down the
media frenzy surrounding the six-week
long trial the outcome and what it means
for the metoo movement plus commentary
by fox news contributor tammy bruce the
fox news rundown is a daily news podcast
where we take a deeper look at the
stories important to you you could
subscribe on your favorite podcast
player by going to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm martha mccallum i'm bill hemmer i'm
shannon breme and this is the fox news
rundown
friday june 3rd 2022 i'm jessica
rosenthal lawmakers are talking about
changes to gun laws following several
mass shootings including one in which 19
children were killed but what kind of
changes might address that in many mass
shootings most guns are legally obtained
so we do need to do more and there's
much room for it but instead of them
passing messaging bills like they're
doing in the house what we ought to do
is try to work together to find common
ground
i'm chris foster johnny depp walks away
the winner in his defamation case
against his ex-wife what's next johnny
depp isn't gonna chase her around for 10
million or 15 million dollars and uh
since she owes him a lot more than he
owes her what they'll probably end up
doing is saying look i'm not going to
appeal but i'm also not going to bother
you anymore
and i'm tammy bruce i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
as our representatives in congress
debate future changes to gun laws the
reality is the people who committed the
most recent mass shootings got their
firearms legally on wednesday there was
yet another mass shooting in tulsa
oklahoma police chief wendell franklin
said the shooter killed himself after
killing four others including a doctor
who recently performed back surgery on
him on june the first
mr lewis purchased
a semi-automatic rifle
from a local gun store three days
earlier he bought a handgun at a pawn
shop the buffalo supermarket shooter
bought his firearms legally as well but
new york governor kathy hokel added you
can
go literally
across the border to pennsylvania
and buy
a magazine
with
30 bullets in it in uvalde the director
of the texas department of public safety
also confirmed the shooter's legal
weapons purchases so what do you do when
in many cases the weapons are purchased
legally while republican senators are
now talking to democratic senators
quietly the house is less quiet with
california democratic congressman eric
swalwell asking republicans thursday why
they even bothered to show up that day
if you're not here for the children
why don't you go to the funeral of the
killer because that's the only place
where the killer is being celebrated
texas republican congressman louis gomer
shot back to
infer by
rhetorical supposed questions who are
you here for
we must be here for the gunman is an
outrage
how dare you capping off the week thus
far in the gun debate president biden
addressed the country thursday night
calling for congress to act saying
executive orders can only go so far i've
been in this fight for a long time
i know how hard it is
but i'll never give up
and if congress fails
i believe this time a majority of the
american people won't give up either
i believe the majority of you will act
to turn your outrage into making this
issue central to your vote
enough enough enough
and when it comes to changing gun laws
that is up to congress i think there
needs to be a conversation
between the parties and we need to look
and analyze the problem of what's going
on and try to fix it rand paul is a
republican senator from kentucky i think
part of me believes that there are some
answers in government and part of me
thinks that there are some things that
are beyond you know governmental control
for example if you look at
the leading cause of poverty in our
country it's having children before
you're married but it's very difficult
to have a law pass to make sure that
people wait to have children
the same way we have uh many mentally
ill sick homicidal suicidal flash
teenagers
and you know trying to ferret out who
are the ones that are going to commit
violence before they do is hard but i
think the ones that are committing
crimes in advance we absolutely should
prosecute
i think the parkland shooter committed
some people said as many as 17 felonies
the police basically never did much of
anything to them
the recent case in new york the guy said
he was going to kill his classmates and
commit suicide and he said he was joking
they let him go
i think if you say something like that
prosecute him prosecute him for
terroristic threatening he'll have his
day in court you take his right to own
guns away so we have laws i think it's
mainly we just haven't been effectively
applying the laws
we know senator cornyn in texas
republican is talking to democrats in
the senate um there is an effort it
appears to try and come up with
something that at least 10 republicans
could back that would address
firearms
where do you think this effort ends up
and
what role do you think you might might
play
well i think there can be uh and is and
it needs to be a room for conversation
to try to stop this but it needs to be
practically oriented it needs to look at
the situations of what has happened and
see what type of legislation would
change that
and you know the house
looks like they don't really care
anything about the circumstances or
passing anything they pass something to
limit magazine size that has nothing to
do with these and actually if you look
at the facts on what it takes to take
down an assailant the average policeman
takes 4.7 bullets to take down an
assailant if you're asleep in your home
you're not a policeman and you're not
that good a shot in all likelihood
you're going to need more than 4.7
bullets to take down an assailant we had
a recent murder in kentucky uh where a
daughter was murdered and the father
came out fired 11 times but wasn't able
to hit the assailant
so the thing is is that people who want
to limit magazine size it's a
non-starter people who want to ban
certain types of guns non-starter but if
you want to look at ways to try to
prevent people who are sending signals
that they are potential killers and are
committing crimes in advance if you want
to look at ways of prosecuting them if
you want to prosecute people who are
felons already who are trying to buy
guns illegally we had several thousand
of those a couple years ago and i think
they prosecuted like nine
out of several thousand
so we do need to do more and there's
much room for it but instead of them
passing messaging bills like they're
doing in the house what we ought to do
is try to work together to find common
ground
senator what about cases in which it's
not so clear you know where you do maybe
have an 18 year old or a 20 year old or
somebody
who maybe isn't so mentally ill or isn't
necessarily showing it like that who
doesn't commit anything or do anything
that is prosecutable um and yet you you
have
maybe somebody who seems like they're
disturbed or having issues we've seen
stories of of shootings being thwarted
of people being arrested of of
high schoolers or others being
confronted by law enforcement because
somebody said something but
sometimes you have those situations
where it's not like an offense
but maybe the kid is acting in a way
where he needs help i mean is that one
of those things where you're saying
that's not a law you can pass to address
that
what i'm saying is is that people who
are committing crimes in advance need to
be prosecuted to the full extent of the
law
and have their gun rights taken away in
a proceeding
for
conservatives it's never been again
about the loss of gun rights it's about
whether or not it's done through a
constitutional court proceeding where
you have a lawyer and a judge you have
representation there's a discussion
debate and then there's a ruling
if it's done that way we're not opposed
to it people are felons are not allowed
to own guns and i don't think any
conservative republicans are opposed to
that
are there situations that won't quite
rise to that level yeah but the
situations that don't quite rise to that
level maybe there needs to be more
aggressive intervention in the
circumstances of the household
and where the child is if it's juvenile
you know there are juveniles that maybe
you can't come to a felony but can be
detained in some kind of uh
situation either as a threat to
themselves or others or for breaking a
lot of other rules
there are quite a few of these cases
there are threats in advance and a
threat is a felony if you threaten to
kill someone it is a felony and we
shouldn't let any of that go we should
prosecute it to the fullest i'm
convinced thoroughly convinced the
parkland shooting could have been
stopped
if police had more aggressively
prosecuted that kid
senator i know we don't have a lot of
time with you so i want to i want to
move to ukraine i know you were you
really made headlines with your pushback
on the 40 billion dollars that congress
approved to send to ukraine i think if
i'm correct it was over getting some
oversight on on that um how that money
was spent we know now we're sending
high mars advanced rocket launcher
systems we've sent howitzers uh we've
heard about you know
timelines for training ukrainians on
these weapons i've heard
you know
both sides right mostly on social media
why are we engaging russia like this by
proxy you know sending these weapons and
then you hear ukrainians say you know
really you think things could escalate
even more it's it's done you know mary
opal bucha slaughter you know please
help us i know you have thoughts as you
watch both sides of that
for me it's primarily about fiscal
conservatism and fiscal responsibility
we don't have 40 billion to give them so
the 40 billion dollars had to be
borrowed when we borrow it the federal
reserve prints it up and that creates
more inflation or we borrow it from
countries like china it doesn't make
sense to borrow money from china and
send it to ukraine does it make us
stronger
cause freedom stronger i have great
sympathy for the ukrainian cause but
that would be sort of like telling a
person who is you know deep in whole and
in danger of not being able to feed
their family they say well there are
people poorer than me and i think i'm
going to go to the bank and borrow a
thousand dollars and give it to homeless
people even though i might become
homeless because of this
irresponsibility so no having sympathy
for a cause doesn't mean you're you can
be a profligate spender or that you can
be irresponsible so no we don't have any
money to give to ukraine we have rampant
inflation across the land we've got
people who can't store to fill up their
their our cars and trucks now we have
widespread inflation across all items
for food we have shelves where we don't
even have baby formula for goodness
sakes and people want to ship our our
money that we have to borrow we want to
ship borrowed money to ukraine it really
absolutely makes no fiscal sense at all
um a little bit of politics before i let
you go we know the president's uh
spokespeople have been talking about
republicans generally now as ultra maga
really criticizing uh republican senator
rick scott's plan for the economy you
know saying republicans basically have
nothing and
i guess sort of mockingly saying and
asking you know what's the alternative
um i know some republicans say hey we're
not the ones in power you guys are we
don't we don't need to have the
elaborate plans but my understanding is
you you do have a plan
yeah my plan is we should balance our
budget i mean if you want to get rid of
inflation quit borrowing so much quit
digging the hole deeper
and i think this is a plan shared by
most americans if you ask most americans
should we borrow money to do crazy
research like studying whether or not if
you take a selfie of yourself smiling
and you look at it later does that make
you happy
when we do research it costs millions of
dollars studying the meeting call
of the male panamanian frog to see if
it's different for the country frogs
than it is for the sea frogs when we
spend millions of dollars studying
japanese quail to see if they were
sexually promiscuous on cocaine i think
american taxpayers see that and they're
they're outraged by it and they don't
want more of it they want less of it and
they want a smaller more frugal
government and that's what i'm offering
balance the budget over five years and i
think you'd see strength in our country
and in our marketplace in a booming
economy like you haven't seen in a long
time
is that is that what's called the
pennies plan or or am i getting ahead of
you here
as we
ensued with bigger and bigger spending
with the pandemic bailouts it no longer
became feasible to do a freeze or even a
penny plan this year's budget that i
will introduce in the next week in
washington will be a six penny plan we
would then get to a point where as
the economy grew
we wouldn't be under so much pressure to
cut services and to cut um uh various
functions of government that people
actually want you know we don't have
enough money for medicare and uh social
security both of them are trillions of
dollars in the whole and we do need to
think of shoring these uh programs up
before we get uh too induced not sending
money overseas
one more for you you are going to face
former state lawmaker charles booker
this fall um the democratic nominee for
senate he's made an ad
as you know wearing a noose
saying you held up a federal
anti-lynching law several years ago
we know that you went on to back and
help create the emmett till antonin
lynching law and you worked with
democratic senator cory booker on that
what do you make of
this and and your opponent's tactics
here
you know it kind of reminds me of jesse
smallett you know sort of an attention
getting hoax based on a lie
he says i blocked something from
becoming a law well i'm actually a
co-sponsor of the emmett till
anti-lynching law i was also
the original author of the marie
thompson anti-lynching law but i wanted
to get it done right so we worked with
the authors got the language changed and
got it passed
and so for him to you know think he's
just smalling a noose on his head i mean
that's sort of bizarre and i think
really demeaning to those who've lost
their lives
senator rand paul thank you so much for
your time
thank you
[Music]
this is tammy bruce with your fox news
commentary coming up
johnny depp wins his defamation case
against his ex-wife amber heard the jury
of seven in virginia not believing her
claims of abuse made publicly in the
washington post and again in court do
you find that mr depp has proven all the
elements of defamation answer yes the
judge in the case penny has karate as
against amber heard we the jury award
compensatory damages in the amount of
ten million dollars plus period of
damages of five million dollars that are
capped in this case at 350 000. def
testified about the accusations that is
not a thing
that anyone is going to
put on your back for a short period of
time i will live with that for the rest
of my life don't call me a liar it's all
i said just don't call me a liar amber
heard spent a lot of time on the stand
herself and the jury apparently was not
convinced she calls the verdict a
setback for women depp says in a
statement truth never perishes i was not
surprised by the verdict at all what i
was surprised about was basically the
trial itself and the evidence that was
induced there from jonah spillboar is a
criminal defense attorney johnny depp
had a really tough job because johnny
depp's job was to prove a negative in
other words his job was to prove that
something didn't happen specifically
johnny depp had to prove that he did not
sexually or physically abuse amber hurt
and while it sounds easy to prove a
negative it sounds easy to to say i
didn't do something it really from a
legal standpoint is not easy to do and
the way johnny depp did that the way he
accomplished that was to prove that
amber heard was lying and his team did
that masterfully they had ample evidence
to demonstrate that to the jury they
were ultimately successful so uh
that made the verdict
not surprising at all
part of what i can't get my head around
here with with all of this is who
benefits
if if amber heard was lying about being
abused the whole time what benefit other
than unless it's just
marital vindictiveness ex-marital
vindictiveness other than that what
benefit does she get by claiming the
abuse what benefit does he get if he did
abuse her by bringing this case that's
gonna that's gonna drag him through the
mud
okay so you raise a couple of really
good questions the as far as i can tell
amber heard what she did was attempt to
elevate her status in hollywood
by pitching her wagon to the me too
star for lack of a better word right she
had a movie coming out she had
you know some degree of success but
certainly not to the level of johnny
depp certainly not to the level of a lot
of other people in hollywood
um you know we were coming off the
frenzy the me too frenzy which is what
this movement was when it first came
about and it was a perfect storm of an
opportunity for her to try to make her
name
better in hollywood and attach herself
to a cause that
its underpinnings have some good
merit and and soundness to it but
it really has been taken uh far too far
johnny depp on the other hand um the the
best that i can tell and i understand
why he wanted to bring this case to
restore his name which is very important
it reminds me of a saying my grandfather
used to have which is a thief will rob
you but a liar will hang you and johnny
depp had basically said enough is enough
i didn't do these things and even though
he knew he had to have known chris that
he was going to have to just open
himself up and give the public more
information more personal information
about himself that we never would have
known and didn't need to know but he had
to do that in order to get where he
ultimately got so it was worth it to him
it was worth it to him to almost you
know lay himself bare in order to clear
his name and his character and that's
what defamation cases are all about it's
defamation of character that's the full
name of the cause of action it's not
defamation of anything else it's
defamation of who you are your character
and johnny depp had to do that math and
figured this is the only only choice i
have and and he was right
this was a case that had a lot of people
taking sides um
for better or worse some some opinions
based on facts some not you know people
saying look amber heard just a liar you
had people saying there's another case
of a woman being treated unfairly and a
man getting away with abuse have you
been following any of the social media
discourse for lack of a better word and
what if anything or have people just
been getting wrong
so i have been following and i was
almost pleasantly surprised to see that
johnny depp seemed to have won in the
court of public opinion
very early on in this case and i wasn't
convinced that that was going to happen
to be honest with you i wasn't but it
did and i don't think johnny depp was
winning because he is johnny depp and
you can call him a powerful man i get
that he's a celebrity but he's not all
powerful and amber heard's take on this
as well i lost because johnny depp is a
powerful man no that's not it because i
watched every single day of this trial
she lost because she was dishonest and
that was illustrated throughout this
trial and thankfully in the court of
public opinion and in the court of law
people were not willing to give her a
pass
simply because she's a woman
claiming abuse because the very
important fact here is that's not gonna
fly nor should it have ever flown if it
ever has if you're telling the truth and
you're a victim of abuse you're one
thing if you are lying about being a
victim of abuse you do not deserve the
deference
of a of a jury or of our legal system
because our legal system does not and
should not protect people who lie in any
forum not just in the mewtwo movement
not just when it comes to sexual abuse
in any form we do not protect liars nor
should we is this a bit of a unicorn
case because of because of the fame
involved
is there any chance that this could be
replicated in other abuse cases
in my practice for example when you
handle divorces or family court cases i
see this every day but it's on a much
smaller level in that nobody knows who
the parties are when i walk into family
court and i have a wife or a girlfriend
who's claiming that her husband or her
boyfriend abused her and she's got her
hand out for an order of protection and
she 99 of the time will get one before a
hearing
that nobody knows about that that that's
a common occurrence and also 99 of the
time if you're representing the person
who's being accused he or she will look
at you and say but i didn't do it i mean
exactly the same scenario but we don't
have the paparazzi pictures to prove it
wrong we don't oftentimes have the
evidence to demonstrate the negative
that it didn't happen so it becomes on
this level becomes almost standard
operating procedure that you can walk
into a court say you were abused get
your
order of protection get somebody kicked
out of their home that's how it works
and now you you the the playing field is
no longer even now the person with that
piece of paper has the advantage and
they can use it as such
there's no quick or easy way to stop
that from happening but
maybe in the back of normal people's
minds non-celebrity minds
judges and attorneys and parties will
will bear this in mind and say well wait
a minute maybe we shouldn't just
automatically believe without asking a
few questions first and that could be a
good thing just a few questions first uh
her's legal team plans to appeal um what
would the possible grounds for a
successful appeal be whether or not you
see any what what could they claim i
think amber heard will be wasting her
money if she appeals but the appeal will
always go toward whether there was some
legal discrepancy that the judge ruled
on the wrong way and what we saw this
judge do and she was a pretty good judge
there was a lot of objections in the
course of the trial and she would rule
one way or the other so
uh one of the basis for appeal might be
you know for one or ten or a hundred of
those legal rulings on the objections
perhaps the judge got it wrong meaning
maybe information came in to the child
that shouldn't have or maybe information
was suppressed it did not get entered
into evidence and it should have those
are typically some of the bigger uh more
common issues on appeal but let me say
let me also say this just sort of like
back room brass tacks how this works in
real life she's now got a judgment
against her for 15 million dollars
johnny depp will have a judgment against
him for two million dollars which if you
think about it this way this isn't funny
but i thought about it like it it she
wanted amber heard wanted a hundred
million dollars the jury gave her two
million dollars that's the equivalent of
giving her two cents on the dollar
that's what the jury thought about her
counter claim for what that's worth
what's her money what is her money
what's her money for like why why why is
she awarded anything
because on one of the counts of her
counter claim the jury found that um
johnny depp's previous lawyer had either
he said something in a publication or he
tweeted something that was untrue
about amber and her friends and so this
look it shows that the jury went through
all of the allegations they went through
all the jury forms very carefully and
found that that one statement made by
johnny depp's lawyer was on johnny
depp's behalf and that it wasn't true so
they basically
gave her a nominal amount compared to
what she wanted but no money is going to
change hands because in a case like this
johnny depp isn't going to chase her
around for 10 million or 15 million
dollars and uh since she owes him a lot
more than he owes her what they'll
probably end up doing is saying look i'm
not going to appeal but i'm also not
going to bother you anymore and this
case will die
on the vine there's no point in
appealing if johnny depp isn't going to
go after her for the money and i
seriously doubt he's going after her for
a dime that wasn't what the case was
about he got what he wanted he got what
he wanted before the jury came back
yeah i mean so he gets 10 million
compensatory 5 million punitive damages
the judge says well that's cap the
punitive damage is at 350 000. so let's
call it 10 million um what happens in a
case like this even if it's a much
smaller amount if what happens to the
defendant not the defendant but what
happens if the loser in the case just
can't pay
what if she doesn't have 10 million
dollars laying around so if the loser in
the case can't pay then then
in this case for example she'd have a
judgment uh against her that can be
executed at some point in the future if
she can pay which also sidebar i think
amber hurd is going to be hard-pressed
to get hired again it's going to be who
would hire her tomorrow i dare say
nobody
maybe in a few years from now if this
dies down maybe she'll get some more
work so her future prospects for income
are going to be i think very different
than they were before this trial but she
could also file for bankruptcy
celebrities have done that before and
that would wipe away the judgment so it
really and people you know again take
this out of the celebrity realm people
who get judgments against other people
think that it's an automatic payday it
is far from it
uh jonas billboard criminal defense
attorney thank you very much for talking
to us today
uh it was my pleasure this was a
fascinating trial and i really
appreciate speaking with you about it
[Music]
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from fox news for amazon
alexa just say alexa play news from fox
in fox news it's the latest when you
need it on demand from fox news and
amazon alexa subscribe to this podcast
at foxnewspodcasts.com
and now
some good news with tanya j powers
a police officer in new york has a new
pet after rescuing a kitten that had
gotten stuck under the hood of a car
last week a caller reported that a
kitten had gotten stuck between the
car's engine and the firewall in the
town of ramapo police department in
rockland county new york documented the
incident
in a facebook post the department said
the black and white kitten was freed by
officers with the car's jack and unhurt
officer christine winter was one of the
first responders who was at the scene
and she's given the kitten a forever
home she says her new pet is four weeks
old and she has named him otto
it's not the first time winter has come
to the aid of an animal that needed it
otto joins her other cat ella who is
also a rescue tanya jay powers fox news
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind the most unlikeliest
of places continues to signal a possible
inflection point in the left's ugly woke
culture war against our nation
netflix the streaming service had gained
a reputation for being the king of woke
like many other american companies they
seemed more concerned with genuflecting
to leftist activists and placating them
by focusing on democrat approved
political programming first it was
disney which in march embarked on a
disastrous adventure by taking a very
public stand in woke politics as they
pledged action to defeat a florida bill
meant to empower parents their stock
crashed and americans of all stripes
made clear their significant disgust
with a house that mickey belt then in
april netflix announced a loss of 200
000 subscribers in the first quarter of
2022 and their stock crashed 37
in one day talk about a wake-up call
upon news of the subscriber and stock
plunge elon musk tweeted what everyone
was thinking quote the woke mind virus
is making netflix unwatchable
the reasons for the disney and netflix
disasters are varied but both companies
have publicly displayed a disturbing
shift into woke politics when an economy
gets tight and people have to make
choices about where they spend money the
first to be cut will be companies who
have taken for granted and insulted
american consumers for far too long on
top of that netflix's troubles may just
be starting cbs news reports that
netflix acknowledged its problems are
deep rooted by projecting a loss of
another 2 million subscribers during the
april june period
that deep rootedness is in part the woke
activists they've hired and going on a
woke programming binge
but all of that seems to be changing it
appears leadership at the streaming
service have suddenly realized what the
left has been feeding them is not health
food it's cyanide netflix has acted to
save itself and that means quickly and
definitively ending its love affair with
wokism by laying off at least 150
employees they had previously hired to
work on woke programming and issued a
memo to its staff rebuking censorship
the daily mail reported quote netflix
announced a new crackdown on woke staff
who try to interfere in shows they deem
harmful or which leave viewers feeling
unsafe
it wasn't just leftist personnel who
were shown the door a whole lineup of
oak programming met its end as well the
most famous of which is meghan markle's
doomed animation pearl about a socially
conscious girl said to have been based
on megan herself other scrapped projects
included anti-racist baby and stamped
racism anti-racism and you
two adaptations by critical race theory
expert dr ibram x kendy reported the
daily mail
all gone because it finally became
apparent that no one wants what the left
is selling no one is buying the
denigration of america and everyone
rejects this disgusting effort to train
americans especially children to think
as racists and with racist stereotypes
at least netflix now seems to understand
or accept just how wrong they were but
it's not a stretch to recognize if their
subscriber base in stock hadn't taken a
hit none of these changes would have
happened mostly this is a reminder to
make sure your voice is heard when it
comes to what stocks are in your
portfolio what you subscribe to and what
effort you support
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown
stay up to date by subscribing to this
podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network i'm
ben dominic fox news contributor and
editor of thetransom.com daily
newsletter and i'm inviting you to join
a conversation every week it's the ben
dominic podcast subscribe and listen now
by going to foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes